[Música]
Argentina y Países Bajos clasificaron a
cuartos de final del mundial de fútbol
de Qatar y ahora se verán las caras la
albiceleste venció 2-1 Australia y La
naranja mecánica le ganó 3-1 a Estados
Unidos Tenemos reporte desde Qatar
en Brasil Después de tres días de
intensas lluvias las inundaciones deban
cerca de 30 localidades del Sur del país
es el caso de saujo Batista donde los
habitantes Todavía no saben cuándo
volverán a sus casas les traemos la
historia
luto nacional en República democrática
del Congo por la masacre de decenas de
civiles el gobierno estima en más de 100
el número de muertos y acusa de los
asesinatos al grupo m23 Sin embargo la
organización Armada niega la autoría de
los hechos
Buenas noches Bienvenidos a las noticias
de franz24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez +
deu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
iniciamos esta edición en el mundial de
fútbol de Qatar porque Argentina y
Países Bajos clasificaron a cuartos de
final los albicelestes vencieron 2-1
Australia y La naranja mecánica ganó 3-1
Estados Unidos nuestra enviada especial
a Qatar Natalia Ruiz con los detalles de
la jornada
Países Bajos y Argentina son los dos
primeros clasificados a los cuartos de
final aquí en Qatar Países Bajos que
logra una victoria tres goles por uno
ante una joven Estados Unidos Don freeze
el hombre de ese partido dio las dos
asistencias para los goles de de Pai y
de bline y luego se dio el gusto de
marcar su propio gol mientras que los
Estados Unidos descontaron gracias a
Bright Estados Unidos que pecó tal vez
por juventud muchas veces y que todavía
se nota que le falta un poco un nivel
para poder medirse a los grandes
europeos En todo caso los de lo ibanga
el que van por muy buen camino él que
dijo que su objetivo es llegar a la
final y ser Campeones el otro partido
que se disputó el día de hoy fue aquí en
el estadio hamad binali entre Argentina
y Australia Victoria dos goles por uno
de la albiceleste ante cuarenta y cinco
mil espectadores Que no dejaron de
corear de alentar de saltar a lo largo
de todo este partido poniéndonos casi la
piel Pues de gallina a lo largo de todo
este partido y coreando ese nombre de
mes y Messi Messi cuando él abrió el
marcador en el minuto 35 luego sería
Julián Álvarez quien pondría a Argentina
por delante de Australia una vez más con
ese segundo gol que llegó finalmente por
un error garrafal del Arquero Ryan
Álvarez supo aprovechar la oportunidad
pero bueno Australia consiguió
finalmente Eh pues consiguió el gol
gracias a goodwin con una disparo que
finalmente da en una rebote sobre
Enzo Fernández y Argentina Pues que
trató de temporizar el partido trató de
cortar un poco la revoluciones parecía
que ya tenía el partido en el bolsillo y
finalmente Australia también fue
poniendo mucha presión sobre Argentina
hasta el último segundo y terminó siendo
Diego Martínez precisamente quien no
había estado muy bien a lo largo de este
partido salvando a la selección ya en
los últimos instantes de este encuentro
para que se evitara Pues el empate de
esta manera son Argentina y Países Bajos
los que van a medirse en la en el
partido de dos equipos que se conocen
muy bien tienen todo un historial
llenado mundial es la última vez que se
enfrentaron fue en Brasil 2014 los
argentinos pasaron en ese momento a la
final
y en pleno mundial aficionados
futbolistas la FIFA y la conmebol
dedicaron sus pensamientos a Pelé Y es
que la leyenda del fútbol brasileño está
ingresado en cuidados paliativos en el
hospital Albert Einstein de Sao Paulo
después de que la quimioterapia ya no
tuviera el efecto deseado en el
tratamiento de su cáncer de colon
previamente hablamos con el periodista
Patricio de la barra sobre la
importancia de Pelé en la historia del
fútbol
para mí fue uno de los mayores iconos
del fútbol mundial un jugador que superó
todas las marcas se superó marcó más de
mil goles incluso tuvo En diversas
partes del planeta yo no conocí en Chile
incluso cuando deja pequeño ya era un
gran Astro en 1958 recordemos que venció
ese primer mundial y de ahí para
adelante se tornó para mí el mejor
jugador de o el mejor atleta de la
historia del fútbol mundial participó en
otros mundiales el 62 posteriormente
después estuvo en el mundial y seis
Lamentablemente salió lesionado fue
campeón en 1970 Y a partir de ahí
comenzó a abandonar el fútbol pero no
dejaba de participar de torneos que eran
creados en el mundo entero Incluso en
África llegó a paralizar una guerra
entre dos países para ver a Pelé decir
algo mayor algo que ningún otro
deportista seguramente lo ha alcanzado
en el mundo en estos momentos él se
encuentra recluido ahí en el hospital
Albert Einstein y está en no todo bien
cuidado intensivo está en una sala común
incluso la hija Flavia recientemente
criticó un poco a la prensa por esta
preocupación mayor con respecto a la
salud de del Astro del exastro del
fútbol diciendo que lo actuaban en forma
maliciosa esperando lógicamente un
desenlace que todavía no se ve venir
porque él está claro
defendiéndose de un cáncer al al colon
que se desparramó por otras otras eh
otros órganos pero que todavía está
lúcido y muy bien incluso respondió al
homenaje en Qatar no y en Brasil las
inundaciones causadas por tres días de
Fuertes lluvias han dejado ciudades
completamente devastadas es el caso de
saujo Batista en el sur del país donde
los habitantes esperan que baje el nivel
de agua para regresar a sus hogares
Andrés granadillo tiene los detalles
las Fuertes lluvias en Brasil dejan a su
paso devastación en Sao Joao Batista en
el estado Santa Catarina el 95% del
municipio quedó afectado viviendas
vehículos y casas quedaron dañadas lo
mismo ocurrió en otras 30 ciudades del
estado
el agua llegó hasta este tejado de aquí
yo estaba al otro lado de la calle en la
casa de mi vecino y vi como el agua
llegaba hasta la puerta había algunas
cosas que había puesto encima de mi
cocina pero la alacena se vino abajo con
todo batidora licuadora todo se fue al
suelo
y guardapopa baby los habitantes
desesperados andan por las calles con
sus enseres mojados una de las afectadas
tuvo suerte en comparación con otras
personas que lo perdieron todo
hubo gente que pasó peor ahora pasó un
señor de edad y su casa quedó destruida
sin duda hay otros que tuvieron peores
estragos
la crecida de las aguas fue de 1,6
metros el equipo de protección civil
declaró el estado de emergencia mientras
el gobierno local creó un comité de
crisis muchos se refugiaron en un
albergue mientras están a la espera de
que la pase y puedan volver a sus casas
con lo poco que les queda tras La
tempestad viene la calma pero también la
incertidumbre que trae consigo la
tragedia
hoy 3 de diciembre es el Día
Internacional de las personas en
condición de discapacidad en Venezuela
las autoridades defienden que los
derechos de estas personas están
reconocidos y protegidos sin embargo
organizaciones no gubernamentales y
población afectada denuncian que las
garantías se quedan solo en el papel
nuestra corresponsal en Caracas Daniela
Zambrano preparó el siguiente informe
Carlos Fuentes ha vivido la mayor parte
de su vida en silla de ruedas tras un
accidente que lo dejó cuadripléjico se
trasladen transporte público pero las
precarias condiciones del servicio y la
falta de infraestructura para personas
con discapacidad complican aún más su
movilización
no hay escaleras eléctricas operativas
este tengo que pedir ayuda a algunos
buenos samaritanos que pasen para que me
ayuden a bajar la escalera y si por una
mala suerte se llegan a caer imagínense
rodar por todas esas escaleras en esta
condición es terrible
desde 2007 en Venezuela está vigente la
ley para personas con discapacidad que
abarca derechos y garantías en materia
de Educación trabajo accesibilidad y
Transporte pero en la práctica no se
cumple Los afectados Como gisandra quien
perdió la mayor parte de su movilidad en
un accidente de tránsito denuncia que en
el país las personas con discapacidad no
tienen acceso al mercado laboral formal
si no trabajo independiente no tengo
este posibilidad de que alguien me
contrate pues una silla de ruedas por su
alto costo también resulta inaccesible
para la mayoría hay quienes como
Lisandro han logrado adqui las gracias a
fundaciones privadas que reciben dinero
desde el exterior hemos entregado 10.000
y pico de sillas y santificando la
cuenta el otro día nos daba una silla
por día que suena tonto pero no no es
bien complicado el pasado mes de julio
el parlamento venezolano aprobó en
primera discusión un proyecto de ley
para garantizar la inclusión laboral y
la adecuación de los espacios de trabajo
para personas con discapacidad la
Organización Mundial de la Salud estima
que en Venezuela y cerca de cuatro
millones y medio de personas con algún
tipo de discapacidad sin embargo el
último censo oficial hecho en el país
fue en el 2011 la falta de estadísticas
dificulta la atención de esta población
en Ucrania la Navidad estará marcada por
la guerra entre otras cosas sin muchas
luces ni adornos debido a la crisis de
energía en el país por otro lado los
aliados europeos también temen escasez
energética derivada de las sanciones
impuestas a Moscú el presidente francés
Emmanuel macron pidió calma y se mostró
seguro frente a las medidas adoptadas
por su gobierno para contrarrestar los
posibles cortes de energía
una plaza vacía Y una promesa de
austeridad chef Recibió la temporada
navideña sin luces ni adornos el centro
de la capital ucraniana suele ser gala
de un enorme árbol de navidad de más de
30 metros esta vez ante los ataques
rusos a la infraestructura ucraniana su
tamaño se verá reducido a más de la
mitad y estará adornado con símbolos del
ejército ucraniano una muestra simbólica
de la crisis energética que vivió
Ucrania y Europa la llegada de un
invierno inusual preocupa al viejo
continente en donde se han anunciado
posibles cortes de Electricidad Y aunque
el panorama parece gris las autoridades
de algunos países europeos hacen un
llamado a la calma No entren en pánico
eso no tiene sentido
hay un trabajo legítimo realizado por el
gobierno para prepararse para casos
extremos que es por supuesto la
necesidad de cortar la electricidad
durante algunas horas en el día Es
normal que el gobierno se prepare para
un caso extremo porque como nos han
demostrado los últimos años a veces
sucede lo impensable
en paralelo Europa Busca soluciones
Bélgica inaugura la mayor planta de
almacenamiento de energía eléctrica de
Europa continental afuera de una pequeña
ciudad belga estos contenedores son
capaces de satisfacer la demanda máxima
del país un paso hacia la transición
energética hasta ahora la capacidad de
producir rápidamente significaba muchas
centrales eléctricas de petróleo o
centrales eléctricas de gas que
activamos en cualquier momento con este
nuevo tipo de Central eléctrica es
posible prescindir por completo de los
combustibles fósiles ante una posible
crisis energética la comisión europea
planteó Establecer un tope para los
precios de gas en toda la Unión Europea
una determinación que ha generado
choques entre los ministros de energía
de muchos de los países miembros
burkina faso suspendió la retransmisión
a la radio r fi de Francia nuestra
emisora hermana el gobierno militar
acusó al medio de emitir informes falsos
y dar voz a los militantes islamistas la
censura se produce después de que la
radio emitiera el mensaje de un líder de
un grupo militante de momento el medio
no ha respondido oficialmente burkina
faso no es el primer país en expulsar a
la radio pública internacional de
Francia malí y hizo lo mismo en marzo en
un momento de deterioro de las
relaciones entre París y las colonias
francesas de África occidental
y este sábado República democrática del
Congo decretó luto Nacional de tres días
a raíz de la masacre de decenas de
civiles en el este del país el gobierno
congoleño estimó en más de 100 el número
de personas muertas pero de momento esta
cifra no ha podido ser verificada por
Fuentes independientes debido a la falta
de acceso a las zonas de combate el
gobierno acusa al grupo m23 pero este
niega ser responsable de los asesinatos
los detalles con amal benotball
la República democrática del Congo está
de luto nacional tras la muerte de un
centenar de personas en la provincia
oriental de kivu del Norte allí según
las fuerzas armadas de la República
democrática del Congo y la misión de la
ONU en la región el grupo armado m-23 se
enfrentó a elementos de una milicia
local de autodefensa los combates
habrían dejado decenas de civiles
muertos el sábado líderes religiosos se
reunieron en la capital provincial goma
otro
nos comprometemos efectivamente con el
proyecto de paz en kibú del Norte
apoyamos a las autoridades de la
provincia en sus esfuerzos por buscar la
paz y la convivencia pacífica de las
comunidades llamamos a todos los fieles
y a la población en general para que se
impliquen en la promoción de la paz en
el este de la República democrática del
Congo los combates se han reanudado
menos de una semana después de que se
anunciara alto el fuego y los civiles
están en primera línea tengo muchas
preocupaciones Porque no tenemos Paz ni
alegría al ver como matan a nuestros
compatriotas en las ciudades de
rutsuruñoni y rugarit este nuevo ciclo
de violencia se produce mientras los
líderes de grupos armados y los
representantes del gobierno están
reunidos en la capital de Kenia nairobi
para encontrar soluciones duraderas a la
situación pero hay un problema
importante Cómo se puede pretender
encontrar una salida a la crisis si el
grupo armado más activo el m-23 está
excluido de las discusiones otra
consecuencia directa del conflicto la
cuestión de los desplazados desde
principios de 2022 al menos 350.000
personas han tenido que abandonar sus
hogares Muchísimas gracias por su
atención sigan con nosotros
[Música]